the AfD has never had it
spoken to isolate Germany.
let's take a look,
what is in the AfD's election program for the European election.
it says the EU project has failed,
the European Union
is not considered reformable.
what does that mean?
that is,
from my point of view,
1 clear path to the national,
on nationalism and all that,
what we have seen over the last decades
have experienced in the European Union,
that 1 guarantor for peace was created,
for free borders,
for free action.
all of this would be massively questioned,
when this way is used by the AfD
would actually become a reality.
and who does not believe Me,
who may believe the
Presidents of employers' associations in Germany,
the highest representative of the German economy,
who warns against this very nationalism of the AfD.
and in this respect I can only say,
for me this is an isolation
and for me this is the turning away
of a Europe in solidarity.
and this is the Federal.